so ollie london is a transracial korean
i mean you just said it straight up but
it's so funny yeah i mean
how how are we discussing this yeah
right
dude you see this guy's tick tock like
okay so this guy's had a bunch of
plastic surgery look korean he doesn't
even [ __ ] look
crazy at all so he got this eye surgery
he looks like a he looks like a
four-year-old woman in hollywood yeah
he's just got that [ __ ] duck face
yeah you know
and then he made this tick tock where he
goes korean
in five four three
two one hello everybody welcome
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast
how is everybody doing we have our
returning co-host
ed park v p today everybody
cheers we haven't done a podcast like in
three weeks it's been a hot second what
are you been up to
well um
i've been taking physical therapy okay
that's right
yeah so like um i signed up for a gym
finally right and i'm like okay it's
summertime it's
it's time to start building like muscle
and you know i i got a pull-up bar at
home and i'm like okay let's do full
body and then i did leg day
right and i did some squats
and some kegel exercises and stuff
and then i just felt pain pain all over
like my waist my balls like
yeah everything like my gucci was tight
as [ __ ]
and so i i go see a doctor who
recommends me to go see a physical
therapist and they're just straight up
like
you know you weren't supposed to have
you know worked out
you know your your lower half there like
you actually needed to give it rest
but i'm like i never do like workouts
though
you know and you know when when we box
you can see my knees shaking because and
i have no
balance right and i was thinking oh i
just need to strengthen my legs
but they were telling me is like due to
my high stress levels
apparently i already had these crazy
tight
hammies and thighs and like basically
my pelvic floor you know and they're
saying yeah you need to
rest first and so for like a week
i'm like laying on my back you know and
and not sitting for long periods or
whatever and
that's why i hit you up on that
instagram live i was like
dude what do i do if you can't do
nothing i was getting so depressed
and just say hi bro yeah that's it
so all i could do was lay around and cry
and like
i can't believe he basically has no ass
syndrome like that's really what it
[ __ ] is
so uh you know i've been in
in production and i've been editing for
what the last that's the worst 16 years
yeah right so i'm just sitting for like
12 hours a day but um
you know apparently my my sitting
posture isn't too great
but also you know i'd lost 100 pounds so
i have no cushion on my ass
and i guess i was just sitting on my
tailbone jesus dude
yeah so uh you know
through the physical therapy i've been
learning new stretches i've do yoga
you know i have to do the roller every
day on my thighs
i got this new [ __ ] mattress i
brought her to bring it here myself
i gotta take it with me everywhere it's
like [ __ ] is this what getting old is
like that's crazy i've never i've never
heard of that before
where you like you just develop a
disappearing ass and then you sit on
your tailbone
that's [ __ ] painful dude yeah it's
been painful
and you know like man
when you know you you there are things
you gotta do
like and a lot of it requires sitting
and then you gotta change it up like
man there was this like depression where
it was like man i wanted to work
out i wanted to start getting big again
and
you know because of uh i'm like
you know with keto i was losing a lot of
weight yeah i'm actually off of it now
yeah you know and i've been having rice
now and just staying gluten free
not gaining weight either yeah yeah and
because i'm
inactive that's the weirdest part is how
lethargic i am but how
tight my [ __ ] is yeah yeah so
you know i'm i am getting better though
i am getting better but then you know i
need that opportunity
from you because i was so sad
did you do you roll out two yeah yeah so
like
my roommate has a roller and like hardly
uses it so i just started
rolling like like your hip flexors and
itb
and inside my literally my ass and
and that's crazy like i can feel the
bumps like you know like when i have
knots in my back because the stress
i couldn't believe it there's like knots
in my legs you know yeah that's just
[ __ ] painful dude yeah uh one of the
things that you can do too is
um i mean i you know it's kind of
controversial
well that's not really controversial
asian people have been doing it for a
very long time
but it's like graston right grass and
technique is basically a
gauche it's like it's an asian technique
basically where you'll see it like in uh
different modalities like when like
vietnamese people i think even chinese
people
they'll take a liquid like tiger bomb
right which
kind of inflames the skin it gets it
really hot um
and then they'll scrape great and so
they'll scrape it with like a quarter
or a spoon and so what that does it
breaks up all your blood cells or
whatever
and that bruising causes like either
listen
i'm not a scientist so somebody can
write the the specifics of this but
basically it causes blood to go to that
area and causes it to heal
right so it breaks down like scar tissue
or whatever and they'll do that at like
physical therapy places that people do
offer it
but they do it now with a metal bar well
they'll scrape and scrape your [ __ ] up
and it it hurts like a [ __ ]
right right but it does help especially
like with
with scar tissue because i actually just
started to um
stretch out my knee now right because i
i started jogging for the first time
right in three years and that's just
scary because i tore my knee
right so when you tear your knee like
you have this this mental block
like i cannot tear that [ __ ] again
because when i tore my knee i couldn't
do anything
i just sit on my ass and just cry
i just sit there and just cry every day
like i couldn't do anything yes when you
when you're trying to be active right
but yeah
now just because of anything you can't
control you're just
you have to be physically inactive yeah
so it's like
and it was stretching like i just
stretched my knee it hurts so [ __ ]
bad it still hurts now
but i had to stretch that [ __ ] all the
time it's night and day like before i go
jog if i don't stretch i
literally can't jog right but if i
stretch it out
i start doing like my physical therapy
stuff for it then i could jog no pain
right but if i don't do that
it's [ __ ] painful which is so weird
and like
i can tell mario this but you know it's
been so [ __ ] hot lately right yeah
yeah
because it's hot we're in pandemic i
haven't really cared to dress in pants
clothes or anything cause why what's the
[ __ ] purpose yeah where are we going
yeah right well when you i already
didn't wear clothes
in general as it is right well now it's
just gotten worse like now i'm just in
my boxers in the house all the time
doesn't [ __ ] matter i'm butt naked 24
[ __ ] seven even some of the ads here
like people are like why aren't you
wearing a shirt i don't know i'm in my
house
[ __ ] this is the worst this is probably
one of the most mortifying experiences
that's ever happened to me so recently
uh barbell brigade shout out to them um
they sent me
uh these shorts they're called their
amphibious shorts they're light gray
very [ __ ] light feels like you're
wearing absolutely nothing at all
feels really [ __ ] good i should get a
pair yeah problem is
they also feel just like my boxers right
so i was at the gym and the gym that i
go to opened up asana
all right so before you go into the
sauna you have to uh
switch out your clothes because you're
gonna soak through the whole [ __ ]
thing yeah right
so i you know got a new pair of boxers
new shorts new everything whatever what
not right i go into the sun i sweat it
all out
i switch out the clothes i go out i have
to go to the grocery store so i go
inside the
grocery store right and i'm walking
outside and i'm like damn these [ __ ]
shorts feel like i'm wearing nothing at
all
right bro i i didn't realize i was in my
boxers
in public i went to the [ __ ] grocery
store
in my boxes went through the whole [ __ ]
got everything i [ __ ] needed checked
out and i was in my [ __ ] boxers in
the whole [ __ ] grocery store oh my
god i had no [ __ ] idea
but then i did realize people were
[ __ ] staring at me yeah until after i
was in the car
damn these barb over great you know
shorts are amazing amazing
they got [ __ ] and everything so i
could pick i gotta do a story for them
i went into the [ __ ] grocery store in
my [ __ ] boxers and a shirt
that's terrible i can never go back in
there
and nobody [ __ ] said anything oh my
god
i had no idea shout outs to barbell
brigade you [ __ ]
sons of [ __ ] for making such a
comfortable shorts and the only reason
why i got away with it is because i was
wearing a long tee
so and i would it looks kind of looks
like running shorts because they're
uh they're they're looser boxers they're
not like the type like athletic boxer
yeah so i think i got away with it and
people weren't sure if they wanted to
approach me
because they were a little longer and i
was wearing a long tee so you couldn't
see the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man man it was a vons in pasadena
i will never you can't go back never go
back in there dude
there's [ __ ] children there there's
[ __ ] oh my gosh
i had no [ __ ] idea well speaking of
exposing yourself in front of children
did you hear about this [ __ ] at wii spa
oh my god so listen
all right so what is we spot we should
talk so okay if you guys don't know
korean people love getting naked in
front of each other
yeah that's a yeah that's a good premise
yeah so we just we just
we don't really give a [ __ ] right so we
spot
is a sauna or a sauna you go in there
it's like a whole experience you have
the
the the hot tub you have cold water you
have the
the the sauna the earth room the stone
room where literally it's clay beads
yeah and it's supposed to do a
detoxifying thing um you could actually
sleep
at wii spa and it's like one of the most
more more commercialized uh locations
where you can do a korean song
experience it's like 25 bucks a day
like you can be there as long as you
want 24 7. yeah so like um
if you kind of if just to get uh some
more premise in there like going to a
sauna is
so regular in korean culture right it's
not a class thing it's like rich
poor whatever like people go to it's
like a public bath house
right but the way it is is like you go
through the lobby and then there's a
the men's locker room in the women's
locker room and each of them
have yeah the lockers then you get buck
naked
and then each of them have like i said a
jacuzzi
showers um what do you call it
a dammit where someone like scrapes off
your dead skin
um all that stuff and then um
you can go up stairs and there's
different levels where there's now
communities
well i mean you get dressed up they give
you uh their clothes
or their shirts and shorts a towel and
then
um that second level there's like a
you know massage parlor there's a
restaurant
there's a mana check bang there's a pc
bang
you know and then there's just this
community space where people watch
tv like they love watching the world cup
there yeah i love watching dodgers game
there's a korean picture
you know um yeah and then there's just
different levels of public space but
that first floor is like
you know men's and women but last
weekend um there was some controversy
yeah uh i don't know did you read into
all that so i saw the video
right and i didn't because i looked at
it so early i didn't see
a lot of the stuff that came out after
it right but i did watch a few videos
where it's it's it's
so basically we're just going to put it
out right now what was what it was about
there was a man who
is uh he is transgender or transsexual
i don't i i i don't know the discrepancy
i think i believe he's trans he doesn't
have the the surgery done though no yeah
right so still has
a male genitalia he identifies as a
woman yes
and he comes she identifies identifies
as a woman
yeah by the way full disclosure we're
new to this we're gonna get the pronouns
wrong
yeah so she identifies as a woman but
has male genitalia
right decides that she is gonna go into
the female sauna yeah she exposes
herself to
not only women but but young kids yeah
has full male genitalia yeah so a lady
recorded the situation
and she flipped out now her issue with
it from what i was seeing in the video
she was like
i mean whether whether or not she
believes you know people can be a man or
a woman outside
of their traditional gender roles or
whatever what not i don't know if that's
the case
but she was very upset because he
exposed himself to
little girls yeah it was a nine-year-old
and a 14 year old
yeah and this is the the women's section
of the place so
i guess the situation was he went to the
lobby and he said i
identify as female or as a woman
and because of california state law like
we spa
can't discriminate against them and was
like okay
like they just had to let her go through
the women's area
and yeah from i guess digging in like
what she was saying like complaining to
the lobby
is those poor you know employees that we
spot like i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah
so i guess um she
came in and started undressing and this
woman was there
with her daughter and he just pulled his
or she just pulled her pants down
this is such a weird thing she pulled
her pants down and whipped out her dick
yeah
that's pretty much really i mean this is
not me being hyperbolic this is
literally what happened
this is new to us it's like so i mean
the culture today is going to tell us
what's wrong with that but then
for us like what would we do really i
mean what if this
woman's reaction is her valid reaction
was just that
her daughter's never seen a penis before
yep right and that's her complaint like
he look when i go to wii spa too and i
see some kids around i'm going to go
around the corner
you know i'm not going to [ __ ] slang
my [ __ ] around yeah you know
the best i can do is like you're going
to see my crack yeah you know
apparently this guy you know full
frontal just pulled it down from this
child you know and this this guy this
woman
yeah i guess the idea in her head is
like this
is the new normal what's there's nothing
wrong with this
it is just genitalia you know
women or men or whatever and so i guess
that was the problem
amongst some of the the customers there
like there was
multiple people who went out to complain
to the lobby
yeah yeah and it was interesting too
because when i was watching the video
there was a guy saying that i don't find
a problem with this either right
which okay this is this is the weird
part for me right
so i remember specifically on the jk
news right
yeah where people were bringing up this
slippery slope argument
this is when these when um trans rights
and stuff were
a very hot topic and it was brand new
and we were talking about this
and i thought it was ridiculous for
somebody to bring up the slippery slope
argument yeah right
and i can't remember which episode it
was whether it was a side conversation
but i do believe it was on camera but we
were talking about how people bring up
these ridiculous examples
of human beings that are going to walk
into a sun and just whip out their dick
yeah and it [ __ ] happened yeah and
now i look like a [ __ ] dumbass
like i was i'm like hold on a second and
the fact that this is
uh an argument somebody might have to
explain this to me
because it's i don't understand i'm not
i don't think
anybody here is arguing or saying that
you can't identify as a woman
yeah i don't think anybody gives a [ __ ]
specifically in california i think a
majority of us don't give a [ __ ] what
you identify with
you identify with a [ __ ] dinosaur egg
if you want like you say i'm a dinosaur
ache i'm like all right yoshi get the
[ __ ] out
you know i don't give a [ __ ] but i do
have a problem
when you expose your male genitalia to
young women when ie for one
that kid never seen male genitalia
before parents never had the
conversation with them about it
and for that person to make a stance
that this is the norm no that's the norm
for you right now
it might be the norm maybe 10 15 years
from now but that's not how it is now
well i mean it started with the bathroom
situations right yeah
where even then i was like yeah let them
use the women's bathroom because they're
not
there to be [ __ ] a degenerate
pedophile whatever no i don't believe
that either they need to use the
bathroom
right so they should have the right to
use the bathroom and so when these
bathrooms laws started coming up what
happened
they made all gender neutral bathrooms
right so they made they facilitated
for these situations right how are you
going to ask respond to make a
all gender neutral locker room yeah
a gender neutral sauna like they've only
it's been built there for years
yeah we have two spots yeah right and so
i see the problem was that they were
like oh then we'll enact the law
and then it'll things will work itself
out but it's like
no it's not the same as just bathrooms
at all
yeah this is a situation where you
expose yourself you know this
is a very tight cultural thing this is a
level of comfortability
for a lot of people you know because
you're not in the bathroom just taking
everything off
you know you're in your stalls yeah you
know and you do your business and you go
it's gonna take a minute or two
at max yeah and and the thing is too
it's like
i think for me when i think about it and
i'm also trying to be careful with the
things that i say because i'm not trying
to be dismissive of how anybody feels
yeah
but at the same time i'm not i'm not
bringing up religion into this
i'm not talking about you know like
religious abominations we're not i don't
give a [ __ ] about any of that [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] we're trying to look
towards the future we're trying to find
a solution yeah the problem
being this was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show yeah
it was [ __ ] nuts and so what happened
uh uh
a day after was that there was a a minor
protest at first right there were there
were people boycotting wii spa
yeah now i'll be at some of the people
that were boycotting we spa were
probably not the best representation to
represent this matter because it was a
religious thing
for a lot of people there were the the
people who are even at like at movie
theaters at concerts
at the street corners but those signs
like repent or burn in hell
it was those types of people exactly
protesting foreign
and here's the thing too if we want to
go ahead and talk about the idea of
protests right
peaceful protesting i'm all about it i
don't have to agree with what you say
but that's the that's the part about
being an american in a country that's
supposedly
supposed to be free yeah you are allowed
to protest you are allowed to
um say how you feel as long as it
doesn't hurt somebody else right
so if you want to go ahead and you know
be a dumbass and you know bring up your
little sticks or whatever and say some
stupid [ __ ]
but you're doing you're not touching
people you're not being aggressive
towards people
and that's what it is you can disagree
with it all you want
well this situation got a lot worse
because really
[ __ ] worse it always gets worse
anti-protesters came out
and uh apparently from what people are
reporting it's antifa people yeah right
it was ntv you know some people are
saying like oh how do you know well they
had the symbols and everything like
if you look at the photos clearly they
are antifa they were all blacked out
they were covering their faces yeah this
is not an opinion
they were antifa right which is also not
a great representation
of people who are more liberal right
right
so you have two people on extreme sides
that are representing a very sensitive
manner that are too far left and too far
right
yeah right they come together what the
[ __ ] is going to happen people are going
to clash
now the weird thing that happened
especially like in california
right i think everybody is so scared
of hurting people or or doing something
wrong on
in in a social sense that even the cops
are now [ __ ] up right
yeah there are clear videos of antifa
protesters going up to these other
people who are protesting
and once again this is not me agreeing
with those protesters at all but people
have a right to protest
as long as they're not [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and they're not being aggressive and
hurting people
yeah well antifa comes in and they start
[ __ ] these people
up dude they were sucking him in the
face they were tearing down they're
they're ripping their [ __ ] up they're
stealing their like sunglasses and [ __ ]
spraying each other with pepper spray it
got violent it turned into a riot
extremely violent and the crazy thing is
as i'm watching these videos
these people who are in antifa right
anti-fascist is what is shortened for
right
uh it's the longer version of what
antifa is they're recording it
as if what they're doing is okay yeah
they go can you believe these [ __ ]
they sock them in the face it's like
hold on a second when did this become
okay right yeah and i think i got really
disappointed when the cops came in
there was a video of this asian dude
right um and he has like this rooftop
korean yeah
right this girl comes in and kicks him
in the [ __ ] nuts yeah right he pushes
away and swings his bottle at her
right hits her in the [ __ ] head yeah
and you hear the people on antifa
going like can you believe this guy hit
a woman
what what yeah i was watching like dude
these [ __ ] idiots like you you
[ __ ] manipulative terrible terrible
people
manipulative is a really good word for
them it's just like what are you
fighting for
so i i was looking at it kind of just
trying to step out of the box look
look at it as if it's in a jar and you
know
these right-wing protesters weren't
exactly protesting wii spa though they
weren't protesting the business
they were adamantly vehemently calling
transgender people like abominations yes
sinners and that they're burning in hell
and then
pointing everything towards god and
jesus right
and so in their head was just like keep
family safe
keep the children safe in their head is
that they think they're helping wii spot
yeah by the way none of them were korean
yeah right and then you see antifa what
are they protesting
like you know yes transgender rights you
guys are bigots and
you know everybody should be allowed to
go to this business
so none of them are actually protesting
wii spot but who loses
we spa exactly nobody [ __ ] wins in
the end
all that all like i said it was the
worst representation about a manner
about a very sensitive subject from two
extreme sides that had no solution to it
it was people coming through to [ __ ]
somebody else up and there was somebody
and there was a group of people who were
religiously pious they didn't give a
[ __ ]
about the actual problem at hand yeah it
was an adult
that exposed male genitalia to
a bunch of women yeah and children right
yeah
that's where the issue becomes at hand
but these people weren't even
thinking about that they were thinking
about you guys you
you let me tell you something you little
[ __ ] are going to burn in there you
are [ __ ] sinners and abominations you
sodomites all you are going to [ __ ]
burn
yeah and these people come through it's
like well it's all about trans rights
it's like that's not even the subject of
matter either
and so you think it's okay for you guys
to come through and just start beating
the [ __ ] out of people
like i and and the cops just watched
they literally
just watched and then like towards the
end [ __ ] antifa got a dumpster and
lit it on fire like how is that helping
anyone
it was a [ __ ] burning dumpster they
put it in the middle of the street
like what the [ __ ] saved the earth
like what the [ __ ] transgenders have
rights like us
shouldn't like burn a dumpster what the
[ __ ] is that gonna do
and there's they're they're you know as
society whatever you know depending on
anybody's opinion you know progresses or
degresses or whatever
this is gonna be a gray area that has to
be accounted for
right yeah the weird thing is is people
don't care about the adjustment period
they just want things to change right
now but that's
so here's the thing though the law
against
uh discriminating against transgender
people
was two steps ahead of what society is
ready for
or what businesses are ready for now
let's take it way back
uh towards the um towards segregation
right
where there was segregated water
fountains segregated restaurants
segregated buses
all of this right here's the thing all
those things were facilitated to
accommodate everyone
yeah it was just a man-made world to
separate them
but once that law came to pass everybody
could ride the same
bus everyone can drink from the same
found everyone can be in the same
restaurant it's not like
oh this law passed now i have to build a
second restaurant yeah yeah
it wasn't like that the problem with
this law
you know i'm trying to be careful with
my language too is that yeah it is two
steps ahead because
you know how do you not discriminate
against transgenders
at a spa where you're supposed to be
naked you know when they're
nothing facilitates that so far except
telling people
you need to accept this now yeah you
know and so now what we got to wait for
society
to be like you know it's okay to look at
dicks you know it's okay to look at
you know this so i mean i had to look at
another way too
if i was in the mail locker room right
and elliot page came in you know and
then started undressing
i wouldn't have a problem with it i was
thinking you know and i i had to check
myself then if if i was a woman and i
saw
you know a lady with with a penis coming
out
would i have a problem with it would i
have to be like well that's
that's society now you know i had a
thing i would have
a problem with it if my son was there
right that's that's exactly
that was that's probably the biggest
thing for me right i think that
but but there's also this discrepancy in
what makes a woman safe versus what
makes a guy safe
right right and i think that's a lot of
stuff that people tend to ignore
it's like when we when we flip the
script on ourselves right i think the
issue that
maybe uh women can probably chime in on
this too it's a matter of safety
right it's how safe do we feel do i feel
safe as a 215 pound korean dude
that boxes yeah that when a woman comes
in
naked is something going to happen to me
absolutely not the worst thing that's
going to happen to me is my dick's going
to get hard
and it's going to get a little awkward
then you'll be like hmm i'm discovering
something new about myself
right and that's that's my fear yeah
right when a woman and i feel that when
women are
in a locker room right and this person
too let's just say
in this scenario the guy is or the woman
is actually not a transgendered person
and this person is i don't know a
pervert right i'm not saying that's what
it is but this is what people might feel
right right there's a level of safety
involved does do these women feel
comfortable and safe with a man
walking in and exposing his genitalia i
think gender wise when we're talking
about
in this in terms of heterosexual
construct i'm not scared of a woman
coming in naked into my
into my spot yeah the only thing i'm
concerned is that if you are a
full-grown woman
naked as [ __ ] and then my child who's
like five years old sees a naked woman
and then he has to go ahead and you know
think about these feelings before i even
had a conversation about how he feels
about this
that's where it becomes a little
different you know so we got to take
this
what's like a grain of salt because we
weren't there obviously you know
um but by the account of the people who
are complaining was that
he was standing right next to these
children and yeah
she was yeah she yeah and exposed her
penis
yeah right and this other part is also
just
hearsay because it was off of a yelp
review about
um i don't know if you read this where
um a woman
wrote how she recognized this person
like
she's seen her before you know um it's
only that
last week where it just came to a head
and it was just this huge
problem where a lot of other women there
um has seen her before and
left her alone and didn't have a problem
with her but
in her account or review so this
grants this is hearsay this is all
alleged yeah that
this woman would just talk to other
women right next to them in the showers
and just have conversations
but what she would talk about would be
like yeah i still have sex with other
women
you know yeah i still date women yeah
i've had sex with so many other women
you know those kind of things and it was
just like uh okay
or whatever yeah and i guess that's
where they were saying
like this person like this individual
by yourself is like um i guess
what i had to really think about was
just the fact that this became a problem
because
this was this this individual act
you know and for me it kind of just
screams
like the fallon fox situation yeah that
a transgender mma fighter
yeah where it was just a load of
narcissism
it was just a load of what about me
and now i want an opportunity now i
should get my chance now
yeah you know this is me and like
forcing
her upon you know like acceptance
yeah like now you gotta accept me and
putting themselves
in this situation for this to happen
yeah you know
so that's where i was like you know it
seemed like there wasn't a problem until
this specific situation
yeah where they weren't mindful of the
people around them
it was no [ __ ] you i'm me kind of thing
right yeah and i think that's where
that's the adjustment period where it's
like
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends skillshare
is something that i use all the time is
there something that you have out there
that's a hobby or maybe it's even a side
hustle that you want to work on
well you don't know where to get that
information and you don't have good
mentors to teach you how to do the
things you want well guess what
sign up for skillshare that have
everything that you need
for that skill that you want baby so
what is skillshare exactly skillshare
is a online community that offers
membership with meaning it's way more
affordable than
in-person classes these online
communities allow you to learn
at your own pace however you want is
something that i
really enjoy i am taking a course right
now by marcus brownlee one of my
favorite creators
on youtube that teaches me how to script
and rewrite all my stuff on youtube and
i've been doing this for a long time but
it's always great to learn from people
who are doing it better than me
because it's all about sharpening my
skills on
skillshare so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a one month free trial of
premium membership that's one month
of a premium membership at
skillshare.com
brain you're forcing people to accept
this when it is just so new you know no
one has an education on this
yeah nobody knows how they're supposed
to accept it well it happened a while
back too
where we were on a just kidding news and
there was
somebody in the trans community at the
time and this was like 10 years ago
right where um i think a lot of these
topics are subjects in terms of what
trigger words are and
you know what words specifically as
descriptors are offensive
wasn't really known to a lot of people
even people in california as
quote-unquote progressive it is here
yeah right
and we said the word [ __ ] right i had
no
[ __ ] idea and none of us on jk news
knew that [ __ ] was an offensive term
yeah right yeah
i remember that i had no [ __ ] idea
and this person
went on this tirade about how we're
anti-trans we don't respect people it's
like well hold on a second
all you could have said was hey [ __ ]
is actually an offensive term to people
in my community
so be a little careful you know what we
just said oh [ __ ] i had we had no idea
right i'm sorry but instead like that
adjustment period is also important
right because people just don't know
right and also
too when people do things sometimes they
forget that this world is a lot bigger
than the city that they live in
right how you feel about what happens
here in l.a
people are going to feel different about
that in louisiana texas florida
i don't know delaware colorado who
wherever the [ __ ] it is whatever state
or city that you live in
and so there is an adjustment period
there's a part where you do have to
explain this thing i'm tired of
explaining
well guess what a lot of the stuff that
you are afforded right now in terms of
freedoms and stuff like that was
happened because there was other people
who are also tired of explaining their
[ __ ] all the time but they had to do it
in order for you to have the life that
you live
right that's that's what it is yeah you
if you if you really do care then you do
have to be a pioneer
and you do have to go ahead and allow
people to learn
because if not if you just start
attacking people people will shut down
when have you ever cared to listen to
somebody when somebody screams at you
right nobody because the other end of
that would be their emotional response
was like [ __ ] you i've been using that
word my whole life
yeah you know i mean like there was a
situation
um with uh people in
uh georgia and florida like south
florida i guess specifically where
uh the word [ __ ] means something totally
different
yeah i'm out there it's more or less oh
you're a loser you're a [ __ ]
yeah you know and they had no idea it
was a derogatory term for like asians or
koreans yeah
right and then um i think you had a
twitter interaction too
or with someone who was just like oh i
didn't know
well i'll stop using it now i guess yeah
well it wasn't that simple it was that
that boxer kid
uh uh actually i don't even know what he
does but he was the one that boxed
logan paul oh no logan paul or jake paul
uh it was uh ksi and one of his wrongs
he was
calling people gooks but i guess over
there it means the same thing it doesn't
mean an asian person it means like a
loser
but i was like the [ __ ] i'm still gonna
be offended by this [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] and then people were
like you don't [ __ ] know anything
that means a loser
i was like oh so you could say that
about the n word too yeah you say that
about just about anything
you'd be like oh to us it means this or
whatever
and then that then that becomes like i
said a self-centered
kind of idea is just like my freedom
my what it means to me and my individual
list or whatever but
um there's a thing about being part of
this country and this melting pot
is that man as a society as a whole
there's a whole lot of cooperation that
needs to go through but
yeah they're just so naturally tribalist
i wonder too when somebody says like
well you know
when these people who are on antifa
right which i do generally believe that
a majority of them just like to be angry
and this is their reason just to [ __ ]
people up that's just who they are
yeah they come through right and they
and they scream these words like trans
are
this is what a lot of people do they go
trans are people too right
right nobody's saying that they're not
yeah but they'll use these trigger
phrases
and words to make the situation a lot
worse than it is
and make people feel a certain way about
stuff even though that is not the issue
at hand yeah so they'll say
keep hot [ __ ] like that like you need to
start treating
people in the transgender community as
humans nobody is arguing
that yeah yeah but who's arguing that
because now they're
putting the precedent that oh you're a
bigot exactly
you're automatically big you've been a
bigot your whole life
is as stupid as this it's like dude i
[ __ ] hate ramen so you
[ __ ] want to kill japanese that's
that's a proper equivalency that is what
they do really
really well they like to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like that right
people do these false equivalency [ __ ]
all the time you see it on twitter
social media and youtube and now people
are doing it in person it's [ __ ]
insane
like you can't have some those two
things are not the [ __ ]
same and that's the weird part about it
right and so when they hear this stuff
like i wonder why maybe somebody can
clarify this too
is it not a general consensus
that an adult who has male genitalia
shouldn't expose it to children or is
there a fat group of people are like
there's no absolute no
no problem whatsoever i should be able
to walk outside and show my dick to a
little girl
right because that's really what it is
now now where's the line like even
with these separate locker rooms it is
like a fine line of respecting one
another yeah they're still harassing
another you know even in a men's locker
room i don't want some stranger
like cisgender male swinging his dick in
my face
yeah there's still a level of respect
and rules like yo you're harassing me
you know
and i guess that was the issue was like
this guy was like
you know just putting himself out or
herself out there yeah you know
just in front of children which is this
is supposed as if it's a societal
standard that everybody is going to
understand
you know there's a little bit of grace
that people have to have when it comes
to these situations it's a very very
sensitive topic
yeah it's weird man but this is the
stuff too we're just like am i
do i need to [ __ ] move out of this
city what the [ __ ] is going on
right now you just need a gender neutral
sauna yeah you know someone's gonna have
to put up the money to do that now the
businesses have to come up with that
because
these saunas don't facilitate for these
things yeah you know
actually my um my ex actually told me
this story she used to work at a sauna
in
the east coast and she told me a
situation
where this uh trans woman came in
uh and was just up front like i'm
transgender
and i want to use the women's locker
room and she was like
well one second you know and just kind
of saw
what would happen like there just kind
of might be a [ __ ] show she's like no i
have the right
to go to the women's locker room i am a
woman
and she had to think fast was like well
we actually have
private saunas you know luckily that
where it costs double they're it's
usually meant for couples or whatever
and instead of charging her double it
was like we'll charge you
just you know this the half fee you know
and
and you can use the private space you
know you can have a top all to yourself
you can have all of these facilities all
to yourself
you know so it doesn't disrupt you know
the other customers
you know and she was like reluctantly
took it but then after
she got naked she came out and was
naked walking around like saying no
i'm supposed to go in the women's locker
room and was making a fuss
and she had to like get up and like to
block her and whatever and was like
calling her a bigot and all these things
and she was just there to start some
[ __ ] yeah
all of this does is causing conflict all
this did was
just make it a terrible situation for
everyone
but her you know it's it's weird
like like i was saying before it seems
like the the the people that get
highlighted in these communities
right yeah whether it's you know
any kind of hot topic it's always people
who are on the extreme end yeah it's
never somebody who can sit there and
explain their position
in a way that'll help people understand
yeah there's always somebody who does
something that's very self-serving
yeah right it's like making a scene
getting super angry
i mean how different would it have been
if they had a conversation right
and then maybe i don't know what the
outcome would have been but it would
have helped out in in a better way
yeah right where conversation can lead
to a better understanding
yeah and a lot of people who are
highlighted in the media
highlighted in the news aren't people of
those communities
you know and it kind of sucks because we
all eat like even in our situation right
like i say this about asian american
[ __ ]
it's like the most the people who are so
outspoken and
so gung-ho about [ __ ] are the people i
[ __ ] hate
it's like i do not want you representing
my community you're a [ __ ] trash bag
yeah i don't
like some of the people or some of the
you know instagram pages that just seem
to represent all asians
yes like that's not what we're about
either bro if i if
listen i ain't no [ __ ] snitch yeah i
mean but i'll tell you this man if i
told people
online half of these [ __ ] asian
celebrities who who are using
this asian uh asian hate stuff yeah just
as a platform to get their voice out so
they can book more auditions
and have get a bigger following yeah you
wouldn't even [ __ ] believe it because
i already know 80
of people out there who are even
listening this could probably fall into
this too
yeah right i'm not 80 that's a little
high maybe like half right and i
understand
right i get it but like i'll just get
i'm not going to say this name but there
was a very popular asian celebrity
yeah that we all know i'm pretty sure
all you guys know
um i had to do a psa for
this asian american thing right it was
film there was a group of people
everything for it right
yeah um this person is very very much in
the forefront about
um how society today basically uh
emasculates uh a lot of asian men and
how
media and how social media even go ahead
and
you know let makes asian men seem to be
inferior and weak
it's been sprouting despouting about
this [ __ ] for [ __ ] and
ever right uh especially when the asian
hate stuff came on he started putting it
on even more
now this person gets called to do
this psa now i've heard about this
through
multiple people that were also on this
project with this person yeah
and he decided not to
put this video out and they were
wondering why and they found out it's
because he wasn't one of the top build
people
in the group of people who did this oh
great because he didn't come on first or
something
literally that's what it was oh my god
and decided that
this person wasn't going to promote it
oh jeez this is how ridiculous people
are in their social justice [ __ ] a lot
of that stuff is self-serving and it
doesn't go anywhere it's not about
him it's not it's not about me so [ __ ]
it
exactly what it's about other asians too
yeah
that's what i'm saying he's probably
saying stop my hate
you know stop you from hating me yeah
the asian community yeah
like what do you think cancer culture is
about right you think a majority of
cancer culture is about stopping stuff
that's an injustice or do you think it's
about the individual
that gets their [ __ ] jollies off of
canceling somebody
because they feel a certain level of
power that they've got to cancel
somebody
i have that power tomorrow you won't get
to eat feed your family you can't make a
single paycheck
i did that [ __ ] i did this i was at the
forefront of this
it's so self-serving yeah i mean well
it's i
see a lot of people jumping on it like
you know like i said all those people i
went to church with
who didn't do a goddamn thing about me
posting every week of my assaults
of the harassment i was getting and all
these things they didn't give a [ __ ]
but then when the stop asian hate
started going on
all of a sudden they're posting all
about it and i was getting pissed off
like
yo you guys didn't even stand up for me
but now that it's popular you guys
you know are out there on it and like
when it's a trend
i start seeing it as people who are
trying to find a purpose in their life
now
yeah you know like the whole thing with
me going
out to like iraq or haiti and japan and
doing these missions was because at a
young age
i was looking for this purpose in my
life and i found it in going out into
the world and
quote making disciples and quote like
doing humanitarian work and i was
putting all of that passion into that
well a lot of people don't get that in
in their young part of their lives
but then when all of society are now
jumping on the
train of this they're like that's it
this is
it this is the meaning of life this is
how i can actually do
something about it and then but then
what what are they doing
in reality just hashtag something well
exactly like and i
i've i've had a roast people in comments
who came at me they're like what are you
doing for the community i was like do
you know who the [ __ ] i am yeah
or what have you been doing for the past
12 15 20 years
who the [ __ ] are you it's like you
literally just came on the scene because
now
it's really cool to do it now you don't
have to take [ __ ] for it
i had to take those [ __ ] bullets in
order for you to do this stuff yeah so
because i don't do it on your schedule
suddenly you get to go ahead and pipe up
towards me
sit the [ __ ] down you don't get to say
[ __ ] no it's because they feel like they
have a purpose now right they feel
empowered oh
now i can show up david so yeah cause he
ain't doing [ __ ] like
what they love the power they want they
want that little [ __ ] pokemon uh
[ __ ] uh badge yeah you know what i
mean like they took the gym leader down
yeah i mean i
did it you know yeah it's like but he's
one of your own kind [ __ ] you're
on the same team
exactly you know and this is this the
funny thing is
i've wrote about this too it
really feeds into the idea they don't
even understand it feeds into the idea
and that negative stereotype that asian
people are weak because
instead of going ahead and attacking
people or
confronting people who really do need to
be confronted because that's an
uncomfortable situation
you rather do it to people who look just
like you because it's more acceptable
because it's comfortable
so what makes you look weak you are
feeding into our stereotype
like and that's why it's this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends are
you sleeping on a piece of crap every
day
that's because you don't have a purple
mattress and you don't have purple
products i feel sad for you
in fact i hate your filthy guts if you
want me to like you you have to cop
yourself
a purple mattress or a purple pillow or
a purple seat cushion whatever gets you
to feel really good now i have been
sleeping on a bag of crap for a majority
of my life
until i had my purple matches we're
talking about technology with the grid
that keeps you nice and cool at night
because your boy sleeps hot we're
talking about conforming
to your nooks and your crevices in your
body to make your back feel good a
majority of your hours are actually
spent
sleeping my friends that's seven to
eight hours every day for the rest of
your life so you might as well be
comfortable while
you do it so my genius brain listeners
purple is comfort reinvented right now
you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com
brain10 and use promo code brain10
that's purple.com
brain10 promo code brain10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain10 promo code brain10 terms
apply it's all this false sense of
justice
it's all it's not [ __ ] real
especially if it's on social media
you know because you're not actually
creating anything you're not actually
making any real steps
yeah instead you're talking to a guy
with a bigger platform and saying
you're not doing enough yeah
[ __ ] what are you doing
yeah besides attacking somebody who's
going through the same [ __ ] that you're
going through yeah like
how the [ __ ] does that make you a better
person man it's it's just a weird space
to be in man
like i i'm i'm not saying that all
activism is completely self-serving
there's a lot of people doing
a lot of great stuff but it is a trend
that i think that a lot of people can
agree
that we have been seeing so sometimes
people get sick of seeing it all the
time yeah where
we he we see so much self-righteousness
we see so much like patting themselves
on the back
it deters me from wanting to be a part
of that group
right because now i don't even know why
people are doing it it's like do you
actually care right i'm not saying that
you have to go out there and protest too
but a lot of the stuff that we're doing
is easier just to do it online and do a
hashtag than actually going ahead and
being a part of the solution yeah right
no matter what that is
i don't have to go ahead and post every
time i have a conversation about
somebody who says something that was
extremely offensive to me i just go
ahead i just went ahead and dealt with
it on the spot
yeah and that's it and i try to change
that person's mind i don't have to go
ahead and
have a megaphone and shout it out to
everybody about every single [ __ ]
good deed that i did
i just have to go ahead and enact
positive change that's it it's just it's
it exposes internet warriors because it
it really enables the people to have the
power to actually
type something yeah now i can say this
out loud
are you really actually saying it like
you said are you actually confronting
that you know shitty co-worker who's
always asking you for soy sauce
which i've had man like one of my old
jobs holy [ __ ] like three people came to
me at my desk like
hey do you have any soy sauce what the
[ __ ] why would i have soy sauce at my
desk you know that kind of [ __ ] and i
feel
like mayonnaise on you [ __ ] yeah
exactly that's what i'd confronted
and actually do something about it then
and there you know
when something racist is [ __ ]
happening actually standing up for
something
except people kind of get at a loss for
words when they actually have to
confront somebody
it's like man you guys need some [ __ ]
practice yeah
you know this typing it out and saying
your thoughts is
is not real it's still ones and zeros
it's all
information in the matrix it's just on
the internet yeah you know
people's social acuity has gone down a
lot um
especially because of pandemic so all
these bad habits that we had of being
anti-social not bad habits let's say
um not practicing a habit that could be
beneficial for us in the future in terms
of being like personally
uh being personable has dwindled so much
because now people didn't have to be
it's worse now like i've talked about
this even when i was doing the instagram
lives these kids are dealing with these
issues of
kind of re-socializing they don't know
how to do it right
it's easier for somebody to be tough
online because they can't do it to that
person face to face right
and it happens so [ __ ] often and it's
weird and i don't even know how to
reintroduce people to this it's like how
do i let you know
or how do i get you to start stop being
such a [ __ ]
right yeah you can stop being a internet
tough guy yeah stop being an internet
[ __ ] know-it-all
yeah how do i get you to transfer that
type of knowledge and that type of
uh like gusto and confidence in real
life
how it only happens when they themselves
get canceled because they [ __ ] up once
yeah right and they don't even
understand that the difference between
them and a celebrity is that their
[ __ ] skeletons in their closet are
exposed to everybody else but yours
doesn't because you're a nobody yeah no
and not a nobody isn't like you don't
matter but as a nobody in the social
space
like you could say all the pious
[ __ ] that you want and nobody gets
to call you on it because nobody knows
who you are
right like if a million people started
digging through your [ __ ]
you know like what are they gonna find
out about you yeah too you know
you know i talked about this word that
was a remember that kid who did the uh
the asian dress thing you know yeah that
in this world was saying the n word with
the heart on 24
7. [ __ ] that word was glued to
his mouth but he was talking about
racism the audacity of this human being
but
that is a majority of people who do that
yeah the
[ __ ] skeletons in your closet are
[ __ ] ridiculous you have a cemetery
in there
but nobody's snooping around to find
your [ __ ] dirt so be careful about
how you point that finger at people
sometimes right
it's yeah it's a dangerous game because
it's one strike you're out
yeah you know but then um you know it's
like
alluding to uh you know baseball
analogies is like everybody has
a chance to step up to the plate you
know but you only get one swing
you want to get one swing and if you
[ __ ] this up then
you know you're literally out of it
forever you know so there's this social
anxiety with that too
then people have to show up and come up
and be perfect
and that's why the way people represent
themselves
on social media is so entirely fake yeah
because they just can't
you know nobody can know about the
mistakes they've ever made and who's
who's really out there doing the due
diligence in terms of finding either
remedies for
a lot of these terrible situations or
even going out there and getting to know
certain people in a community that that
you have a hard opinion about right
like for me for example uh in terms of
trans rights and stuff
i went out and i was searching for
people who wanted to be on this podcast
who's trans yeah because i want to know
number one what it feels like
yeah what what type of emotional
terminal they've gone through what is
that what it feels like for them to
identify
as a gender that they felt that they
were their whole life i'm so curious
about this stuff right
and i actually went back and forth with
somebody online um about the situation
and this is just one person right and
i'm not basing my opinion on just what
one person told me
yeah but this person also agreed that it
was wrong for
her to go ahead and expose the male
genitalia to these kids yeah right and
this is a person who's also trans
so there's uh there's even a spectrum
inside that community
right because when we watch the news and
we see this person who is a
representative of the trans community in
la say like
this is an act of violence towards our
community well there's somebody who i
had a conversation with
that doesn't agree with that that's also
trans yeah right
so it's like they put themselves in a
situation
to be the spokesperson even though where
there's their opinion you know right or
wrong is only just
one side of a story yeah and this person
by the way is uh trends from from woman
to to male
yeah so you know having that
conversation and i just asked like what
is your perspective on this like
uh and they didn't agree with the whole
exposing male genitalia
to uh to to young women like that like
he didn't agree yeah i mean like i said
even as cisgender people
it's not right but i what we're trying
to understand is
how is it now okay just because now
you're trans
yeah you know like the same way that's
why i brought up fallon fox
like the amount of people who are just
like let her
compete let her compete or all trans
women's in in sports
right like i'm
i'm on the edge of like i don't know i
don't think they should i don't think
it's
fair yeah you know like in new zealand
right now
uh there was a power lifter who made the
new zealand women's powerlifting team
she is 41 years old wow she's had
decades of experience powerlifting as
uh a man oh you're talking about uh uh
this is a
somebody who was in the trans trans
community yeah and now she's
going to tokyo representing new zealand
as a power lifter
she's 41 years old when the average age
for these power lifters
is like 21 to 24. and apparently there's
this
uh polynesian girl who was up there it
was gonna be her
year you know to do it but then this
much bigger stronger transgender woman
took her spot
yeah no [ __ ] at 41 years old you know
listen
i don't even understand the argument
behind that right because now we're
going into like facts and science
this person for their whole life benefit
benefited
from having male testosterone which
clearly
better for building muscles yeah bigger
bone strokes the bone structure and bone
density is completely different and then
this person decides
or maybe felt like this way their whole
life it's like hey i'm actually a woman
now i want to go ahead and smash these
women apart yeah
like yo well cool remember remember dave
chappelle had us
had a stand up about this he goes cool
well how about [ __ ] lebron james says
i'm a woman today and he goes to wnba
and scores 782 points
yeah like how is that how's that fair to
women
yeah how are you going how is that
supposed to work out like uh
filing fox is was an mma fighter she
lived 30 years of her life as a male
and training in mma a very lackluster
male mma fighter too by the way and goes
into the women's division and starts
smashing literally smashing like
hurting injuring putting her fists into
these
women's faces and part of the story was
that some of these women didn't even
know
that she was they were like what the
[ __ ] yeah afterwards it's like
how was that fair competition yeah you
know and
how is that even like how is that not
abuse
yeah either and nobody's nobody who is
on that side
is is is arguing that fallon fox is a
woman
yeah you're a woman but you benefited
benefited from being a male for 30 years
of your life yeah
and this is highly evident in fallon
fox's male mma career
where fallon fox was not that good yeah
and even as a female
mma artist not that good either but the
strength was
the was the equalizer yeah right fallon
fox did lose as a female mma fighter
somebody who was more skilled but that
was very few and far between but that
just goes to show the skill level wasn't
there
so yeah it's possible that fallon fox
could lose but when you look at fallon
fox as
a male mma fighter at the time when when
she was a he he was not that good he was
very mediocre right but comes onto the
female scene
and starts wrecking these women serious
injuries
yeah this is like really high-stakes
sports too like it's
it's just like wow it just didn't feel
right
at all you know it's just you're you're
really hurting these people
yeah it's like i wonder if a fair
competition would have been a
transgender
weight class yeah that would be kind of
dope yeah then
that's fair competition then i get it or
even like with this olympic thing
um this new zealand power lifter
she made it through because she was
taking
testosterone blockers right or like uh
whatever hormone
pills that you know allowed her to have
the
um what's a legal amount of testosterone
for a female competitor
yeah you know meanwhile there are some
of these
uh black women athlete um who were
disqualified from the olympics because
they had
unnaturally high testosterone
and and they were competing very well
but they won't allow them to compete in
the olympics because of that
because they're telling them now they
have to take these like
even in mma they they test for test
blockers yeah like if you
if you have a test blocker in you they
assume that you're taking steroids yeah
right so it's like what the [ __ ] is
going on what are the rules now yeah
now it's all blurred it's just like in
the name of equality but how is this
equal
yeah how is this equitable you know it
doesn't make sense and once again
this is just this is all speculation and
conversation if somebody who is
you know represented this committee
wants to explain this in a way that
maybe that could help us understand
i'm all [ __ ] ears for it right but
it's hard to argue for this for my for
my from my perspective
right right just because i've seen
we've we know the science we know what
it's like behind it the simplest
way for me to see it would be because
there's a male division and a female
division there's
a reason yeah there should be a trans
division then then that
is fair is it not or is the argument on
the other side that's segregation
that is bigotry that is it could be yeah
definitely it's just a it's just a
really
i don't even know what to think about it
right because i haven't been
in a position where i had to think about
it so i really don't know and i don't i
don't think a majority of people no guys
we don't i think a majority of people
don't i haven't been in this position at
all this is still relatively new
yeah so if you guys you know can you
know see what we're doing we're asking
questions
we're saying how we're asking why yeah
you know and we want to
we're trying to figure out the answers
too we don't have conclusive answers
yeah i i have a gut feeling about how i
feel about it now
right it might change in a few years
from now sure but as of right now
do i feel that um a person who
identifies as a woman but still has male
genitalia should be allowed to expose
herself to women i don't think that's
uh that's something that should be
discussed yeah and
i don't think that's there's a clear
general rule of saying yes
and because you disagree with that
suddenly you are anti-trans i don't
think that's fair i think that's a
non-equivalency
yeah i don't think that's i think those
are two separates two separate um
issues right do i feel
that uh somebody who's been a male for
30 years that has benefited from having
male testosterone the bone structure
the muscle density should be able to go
in a cage and fight
uh another woman who has been a woman
her whole life
i don't think that's fair yeah and i
don't think women who don't want to
compete against
a woman who went through that procedure
um should be forced to fight them and
you see people who make the argument
like for them are people who don't know
what god damn thing about combat sports
either but then they're gung-ho about
trans rights
it's like we're on that side too people
should have equal rights
but then when it comes to an
extracurricular competitive
where somebody could die someone can die
it's like that's another story
yeah i'm so curious i mean speaking of
trans too we're
gonna talk about uh [ __ ] that guy
ollie london
oh yeah those lines not blurred like
come on trans-racial
things transracial is probably one of
the funniest phrases i've ever heard in
my [ __ ] life dude
like literally it's the funniest thing
and you know why trent like the whole
topic of being transracial is
[ __ ] stupid it's because now you are
giving people
that the the people who who talked about
the slippery slope argument
yeah right now it's just becoming true
they go it was like a joke before yeah
it's like well what if i was transracial
i'm like that's [ __ ] stupid nobody
thinks they're transracial
rachel dolezal comes out yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] she was the
naacp president in spokane washington
what kind of dave chappelle sketches
this dude yeah
dude rachel dolezal is probably one of
the purest whites i've ever seen in my
life
she's as white as white gets i'm talking
in a college photo dude she looks like a
pirate tale
yeah she looks like if she wanted butter
she had to turn it in the morning
yeah like that's how [ __ ] white she
is she came
out as an advocate for this guy ollie
london uh did you want to
explain who ollie london is so ollie
london is a transracial korean
i mean you just said it straight up but
it's so funny yeah i mean
how how are we discussing this yeah
right
dude you see this guy's tick tock like
okay so this guy's had a bunch of
plastic surgery look green he doesn't
even [ __ ] look crazy at
so he got this eye surgery he looks like
a he looks like a four-year-old woman in
hollywood yeah
he's just got that [ __ ] duck face
yeah you know
and then he made this tick tock where he
goes korean check
and he brings the camera in and points
at his [ __ ] eyes
holy [ __ ] dude the most racist [ __ ]
thing you could ever do you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
dude yeah what the [ __ ] what is the
argument with people who are transracial
they're saying that
it's like i was born korean
because
like oh my god you can't even speak
korean what the [ __ ] is
what are these people talking about yeah
you want to be korean bro go to the
[ __ ] dmz
and serve your two years yeah yeah
i'll respect you then you want to be
korean for the next 10 years i'm gonna
have to yell at you for doing good
things
yeah well we're just gonna tell you
you're not enough
yeah for the rest of your life and by
the way and by the way us
yelling at you and calling you stupid
for being transracial
is probably the most korean thing that
we can do
that is so you just have to take the
[ __ ] abuse when you come home
anytime you do something wrong you have
to go on your knees beg for forgiveness
and the budokura for [ __ ] an hour
straight yeah like you
have not even lived the life of being
korean but he's like i've always
identified as korean for the last
eight years what what
how i bet this [ __ ] can't even
eat kimchi i know
here's the thing the difference between
and that's the thing too i'm so curious
about what a trans
uh a trans person in the in uh
transgendered person
wants that i want a transgender person
and a transracial person to have a
conversation
right because the idea between somebody
who is transgendered
for me that makes sense is that since
the day that they were born
they were cognizant of what their gender
was they never felt like they were in
the right skin
yeah this [ __ ] listened to hot
ones
i was like holy [ __ ] i am as a quality
yeah
that's that's that's the thing if you
say i've felt korean for the last eight
years
not like from when you're about so
that's the thing how do you know that
you've been korean like from when you're
a child like you don't know that [ __ ]
yeah you know so it's so [ __ ]
ridiculous like how where do we even
start
where do we without you know like have a
serious conversation like we just had
for the past hour many minutes
yeah how do you have a serious
conversation about this [ __ ]
you know it's like no dude i'm literally
if i ever see this dude in person
i'm gonna [ __ ] bend him over and i'm
gonna spank him with a [ __ ] bamboo
stick like
how many years have you missed out yeah
i was like bro you gotta pay your dues
now dude
you 100 have to pay your dues i want you
to go to the wall
and then put your hands up for [ __ ]
an hour for doing something wrong
yeah you have to feel like like you're
never enough you have to be a
perfectionist
like you have to have all this
resentment towards your parents
i'm gonna punch you in the face and ask
you why you're crying
you have to be threatened you know with
your life you know you're gonna say
triglet
yeah every day of your life yeah like
what is this [ __ ] what kind of world do
we [ __ ] live in now dude where this
person
absolutely believes that he is in the
right and that that everybody else is
now a bigot because they won't allow him
to think that he's korean you could
think that you're korean as much as you
want but the fact that you expect us to
accept it is another [ __ ] story
narcissism yeah it's that that's another
thing like if you look at his
um social media page he's putting up
all press bad press doesn't matter
it doesn't matter give me attention
attention right his 15 minutes will be
up
and now what your eyes are all [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah you know now what the [ __ ]
are you gonna
do yeah in the shittiest [ __ ] way
possible too you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was so weird looking at this thing i
was like this
i'm we're living in black necklaces
black mirror series yeah this is
literally what it is
the fact that somebody and rachel
dolezal is over here just defend [ __ ]
just disappear like what the [ __ ] why
are you chiming back in nobody [ __ ]
likes you
shut the [ __ ] up it's amazing that she's
still
out there like like i i i thought she
was gone
did you watch the docu-series about her
uh-huh you know the people who suffer
the most in the rachel dolezal conflict
is her children
oh because their children are actually
mixed-race their father's black uh-huh
right
but they're getting made fun of and
ridiculed every day did they even know
their mom was white
i don't even oh that's a really good
question
that she was actually white hmm
oh [ __ ] i didn't even wonder that yeah
i don't i don't maybe they didn't that's
what's kind of crazy and [ __ ] up i
mean
so she was adopted right into a black
family
and then she went to like howard
university
or something i oh [ __ ] i can't remember
i'm not sure if she was adopted into a
black family or maybe she had black
relatives or something i know she has
like a
a black step brother or like oh yeah
something like that there you go yeah
yeah yeah he's the one that exposed her
for being white he was yeah i've had
enough of this [ __ ] it's like [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] white
like what are you talking about and then
she would i think she took photos of
some random black man and said that
that's her father
oh my god transparent yeah it's like yo
what the fire joe daddy what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
oh my god but it's it's it's the lengths
they go to
yeah for what for attention yeah
i really want to know like because let's
say if rachel dolezal was here right and
i would ask her a question it's like
what is the purpose of this yeah
like you know you're white right is
there something wrong about that
is there something wrong that you're
[ __ ] white it's like my whole life it
can't be your whole life that you felt
like this
yeah right because there had to be a
moment there had to be a moment where
you were like
white ain't right and you were like i'm
[ __ ] black
yeah and then i mean it's crazy how many
people she do i mean because she became
the
naacp president yeah she said her goals
[ __ ] high
that's crazy yeah because that would be
great if if if um
let's say i don't know a [ __ ] george
floyd one day when he was getting
[ __ ] murdered he was like i identify
as white
yeah treat me let her stop killing me
that would be great if somebody could
have done that you know what i mean like
there's there's definitely some social
repercussions involved when you do [ __ ]
like this right this guy
and here's like the the annoying thing
about the whole ollie london guy who
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
right yeah and the reason why people
know you is because of this [ __ ]
that you're pulling
here's the other annoying thing about it
too people really forget
when asian people were just made fun of
for liking asian [ __ ]
right and this person gets to hop on
this wave and he goes i
get to be asian now makes sense now from
the past eight years like
the past decade korean [ __ ] got really
hot really popular yeah were you doing
that [ __ ]
20 years ago when it wasn't cool yeah
when asian people were getting made fun
of left and right for the food that we
were eating where it wasn't cool to
[ __ ] go to a far place it was
considered a dirty food
i guarantee you you weren't talking
about that [ __ ] i guarantee you you
weren't saying
you know what i feel like i'm korean you
feel that way
because now it's cool you see people
like [ __ ] bts you know doing
mcdonald's brand deals and [ __ ] you see
them
you know charting the [ __ ] uh the our
billboard 100s
yeah and now it's highly how convenient
in the last eight years you felt like
you were korean [ __ ] guy thinks he's
going to get a wendy's menu made out of
him
[ __ ] yeah go [ __ ] yourself dude you
literally
are making a mockery of our culture and
here's the annoying thing too right
the stuff that says that makes him
korean is only the commercialized stuff
right it's k-pop that's not what it is
to be korean
and even kpop is not even the best
representation of us
it is this extreme [ __ ] crazy
lights and makeup and camera show yeah
you know
so it's like that's another thing this
[ __ ] hasn't lived through the
resentment
of how cool asian [ __ ] is when we used
to be made fun of it yeah like it's hard
to accept these days it is
it's it's there's a sense of relief like
and and pride that k-pop is not k-pop
well not just k but like k-town
even is like so crazy hot and busy and
there's like
so many different types of people now
enjoying and eating our food
but there's something in the back of my
head like [ __ ] you know you used
to make fun of your
classmate for bringing that [ __ ] to
school you know so i'm saying it's like
he keeps saying like i'm korean and he
goes my name is chiming
like [ __ ] a k-pop star's name you're
clearly not korean
like you're you identify as a k-pop weeb
yeah that's what you identify with you
don't identify with being a korean
person at all because your your view of
what it is to be a korean person
is a korean pop star the [ __ ] that you
see on tv
it's manufactured exactly like these
[ __ ] went through the grinder
to become who they're they're
they're made out of this formula man and
you think that's korean like
that's [ __ ] up how [ __ ] ridiculous
is that dude makes absolutely no sense
i bet so jimin is a bts member
i bet that's not even his real name
either it's not it's not his name
yeah none of these guys had their actual
real [ __ ] name
yeah like these hot members kanta
kangta's not even his real name
right it just sounds a lot cooler yeah
like what the [ __ ] are these people
thinking about man i think that's like
the annoying thing about when people
um they say they love korean culture you
don't love korean culture you like k-pop
i hate that i [ __ ] hate it like i'm
not even too particular about certain
stuff but when people say i love korean
[ __ ]
no you don't you like the commercialized
korean garbage that you're [ __ ] fed
you don't know [ __ ] about me
you don't know [ __ ] about my culture you
don't know [ __ ] about what it's like to
get socked in the face
like you don't even know it's coming you
just get a [ __ ] knuckle on the back
you don't know what it's like to tell
your dad to stick out of physics and
punch yourself in the face
it harkens back to my ex you know my
white ex who
who was just a really big k-pop fan
and then when she actually started
dating me was actually not into korean
culture at all
you know yeah she didn't she just liked
all the meat
and didn't like any of the potatoes
right yeah that's exactly what it's like
and i think
if people kind of could wrap their head
around that that's where it becomes
offensive
the argument might be it's like well why
can't he identify as a korean person
nobody's saying that he can't you could
do whatever the [ __ ] you want
no you could say that you're korean i
could tell you right now that i'm like i
said i'm a [ __ ] dinosaur egg
i can say that doesn't mean that it's
true and it doesn't mean that other
people have to accept it and treat you a
certain way just because you want them
to
even when you're especially when you're
doing something that's highly [ __ ]
offensive to
a majority of asian people i bet like
he's gonna say i've experienced racism
by these two guys
my own people
my own people oh my god [ __ ] well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain
podcast if anybody out there has
thoughts on this i'm curious to hear you
might
agree or disagree i'm so curious though
yeah i don't
know man yeah we don't know questions
questions and opinions but i'm so
curious about the the other side of the
argument to that
if you guys have uh a thought about it
write it in the comments if you're
watching it on youtube or if you're
a part of the anchor community go go
ahead and write those comments and let's
have a discussion
uh you can catch ed ed parkvp everywhere
and
uh jeannie springs on thursdays and
sundays and we'll see you all next time
peace